who here watched remember that show boy
meets world did you guys watch the uh of
course
um you guys remember mr feeney his
teacher i love mr feeny well his real
name the actor is william daniels and he
just turned 95 years old
[Music]
magazine talked to william about his
long career and his successful marriage
of 70 years oh i know to actress bonnie
bartlett look at him they met back in
college and they've shared a life
together acting and living as partners
and and william says their secret
is adapting he says when you hurt each
other the key is to recover grow
change and adapt and what i loved about
this answer is it wasn't like um it
wasn't just sugary right it wasn't like
laugh or never go to bed angry it was
about like we change and if you love
somebody now who how they are they're
gonna change as you live 70 years
together so can you love them as they
grow you have to adapt to them i thought
that was so insightful i love that mr
feeny teaching us again
thank you thank you for that advice um
well we've got to take a moment to
celebrate uh the life and work of an
incredible woman cnn reports betty reed
sawskin the oldest ranger in the
national park service well she just
retired rossi at the age of
100. wow
betty worked at a park in richmond
california that is dedicated to
highlighting the works of americans on
the home front during world war ii and
betty was one of those women after
facing discrimination in the air force
she went on to work for the boilermakers
auxiliary union yeah and betty's work
shed light on the diverse group of
americans who supported the war but
often went unnoticed in the history
books and you can hear betty's entire
story in her own words online and the
infos on our website congratulations
betty and thank you for your incredible
service 100 years like that is an
extraordinary life
now last but not least it's time for a
pick from uh drew's little yellow book
we refresh it on our website every
single week and today in honor of
magnolia week it's a magnolia exclusive
okay so i was just in waco texas yeah
with uh you know chip and joe and um you
know i obviously hit the stores and did
a little shopping while i was there um
and i found this backpack and i'm
obsessed with it now i am mrs backpack
um i'm also mrs fanny pack i need a
strap-on
[Laughter]
i have to be buckled up and buckled in i
want hands-free so i'm fanny or back
understand i like an evenly distributed
weight thank you so much that's why i
like a backpack well so i found this
backpack and i thought the size
and the chic-ness of the leather just
really spoke to me um it's the remy
backpack it's made by raven and lily a
fair trade fashion brand that works with
female run businesses around the world
and it's made
sustainably with sourced leather and
it's handcrafted by women who are
artisans in ethiopia so not only is it
beautiful but it has a beautiful story
so i wanted to share it with you guys
[Applause]
[Music]